with a meeting of nato the g7 and the
european union in one day western allies
are hoping to show a strong and united
front but while western forces will
remain on the sidelines of this conflict
for now there were veiled warnings
thursday that could change if the
russian president crosses a line any use
of chemical
weapons will totally change the nature
of the conflict it will be a blatant
violation of international law
and
it will have
wide spread consequences the u.s has
been warning for weeks now russia could
be planning a chemical weapons attack in
ukraine it's now set up a so-called
tiger team a group of security experts
at the ready should chemical biological
or nuclear weapons be deployed we would
respond we would respond if he uses it
the nature of the response would depend
on the nature of the use the use of such
weapons of mass destruction would put
people well beyond ukraine's borders at
risk it's why nato's top military
commander has now activated the
coalition's chemical biological and
nuclear defense elements with allies
agreeing to supply equipment to ukraine
to help with detection protection and
medical support there is a visceral
horror of the use of these weapons of
mass destruction
i think that if putin were to
engage in anything like that
the consequences would be very very
severe i think we are at this pivotal
moment and uh
just from what we know of putin and his
strategy he needs to be able to declare
that he is one in some way and that's
looking harder and harder in terms of
the ground campaign
and the risk of escalation intensifies
as this conflict rages on heather urex
west global news washington